ارتباطا بهذا الشان نقل موقع بلومبرج عن
مجموعه كوني اند ناجل المتخصصه في عمليه
النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه ان اكثر من 100
سفينه حاويات قد غيرت مسارها من البحر
الاحمر الى طريق راس الرجاء الصالح تجنبا
لهجمات الحوثيين واضاف الموقع ان الشركات
تدرس ايضا استبدال الطرق البحريه
والاعتماد على القطارات والرحلات الجويه
وهو ما يرفع تكلفه نقل
للسلع وبدورها قالت شبكه سي ان بي سي
الامريكيه ان شركات الشحن في المنطقه
البحريه المحيطه بشبه الجزيره العربيه
قامت بتحويل بضائع تبلغ قيمتها نحو 65
مليار دولار من البحر الاحمر حيث تواجه
هذه الشركات خطر الهجمات من مقاتلي جماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين في اليمن واضافت
الشبكه ان هذه الشركات
مسار سفنها كنتيجه مباشره لاكثر من ا عش
هجمه للجماعه في البحر الاحمر منذ بدء
الحرب بين اسرائيل وحماس في اكتوبر
الماضي